what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest you want to introduce
yourself
sophie and she is going to show me what
video are you showing me
um it's first time getting drunk with
larae and ravon so i
have never heard of these people but um
guess how old she is guys
she's 12 so she has she's gonna show me
to what the kids listen to these days so
i'm excited
wait you're 12 why are you watching
people get drunk online
what why not i'm not going to ask
questions before this video starts you
guys i just want to say a quick thank
you to my sponsor for this video
me thank you to mario someone for
sponsoring today's video because both of
my friends
have brand deals in their video and here
i am being the black sheep but anyways i
am sponsoring my own video
so thank you mario you can go follow him
on all socials is there anything you
want
anyways i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and watch us get drunk as hell
and again thank you to my sponsor mario
something love you it's actually for the
first time or do you think they're lying
for the camera
they're probably lying
[Music]
welcome back to my channel today we're
doing a what
confirmed the fact that we drank twice
already this is our third time third
time's a charm third time
is the charm and honestly i was gonna do
a video where we don't drink but then
we got drunk twice and i felt like no
yeah third time's an hour i feel super
left out you know me a little
sagittarius a little couple
of times because i want to make sure
that i'm loved by my bffs
maybe you're just needy it's like put a
sock in it today i'm gonna be doing my
first ever drunk video which was
supposed to be my 21st
birthday drunk video but he never had a
birthday because he's immortal so he
doesn't age so today we're going to
change that and we're going to celebrate
his birthday today
happy birthday question do you think
their hair looks good
i think riven's looks good
this this skinny guy this guy okay what
about his
uh what about his decent okay
one to five um i'm gonna give this a
three
this is a one not their looks just their
hair yeah
this a one i i hate their hair
i would say well yeah lorie's hair
i don't know what that is but i like
ravans okay i think that's the style
yeah all messy
[Music]
[Applause]
big little twist on today's video we're
not just getting drunk you guys
we're becoming let's say the powerpuff
girls
okay first shot here we go oh you're i'm
not going crazy
oh you're going it's your video your
video you have
every time larry pours me a shot it's
literally enough for three people
exactly tsunami oh
what is that now can't have the smallest
shot look at this let me see it let me
see
i'm a lightweight oh oh you think you
can get away with this cooler
oh absolutely not fill it up friend
this is this is a sip for him all right
guys
cheers okay i'm the boss
okay let's just [ __ ] take a shot
here's to being 21 honestly also if
you're not 21
please don't drink underage it's not
good i don't like drinking i'm just
doing this
literally for the video not a liar
[Music]
y'all even cheers your shot okay you
need to finish that shot actually
[ __ ] no yes
they're very very into their uh
you can just say again they're gay okay
it's not a pc okay nah we we just
reacted to a video about killing people
okay we could we could say and that's
how you get your friends to drink
i'm back i'm wait i don't even know
their names blossom
bubbles and buttercup okay should we
take another shot
i'm down okay all right you guys second
shot here we go
to the lgbtq community
all right you guys so this is now my
makeup tutorial stop tickling my feet
who's sticking my feet i'm literally
kicking my face
i'm being peer pressure my nail is about
to fall off
okay we're gonna play a little game
called truth or drink okay what should i
start with
first question of truth or drink what is
the secret you kept from your parents
oh i'm gay that i'm gay
in the house one time i snuck a boy into
my parents bathroom and
who is the last person you creep on
social media
um noah galt do y'all know who that is
what the [ __ ] is that
it was the hot werewolf oh my god the
whole werewolf is greg sulkin
that's there we go oh you know who nick
austin i was just creeping on his
profile because it's kind of good
madison wait i think i was too well
that's my answer just today
yeah today i was talking a couple cause
he posted and i was like what is he up
to okay wait
next question where is the weirdest
place you've ever gone to the restaurant
um in my car on myself
uh in my bed larry one time [ __ ] himself
three times in one night
this is because someone brian's mom did
a witch follow me to cleanse my body
and i'm not even kidding i shot himself
three times in a row
ah yeah
they're like oh that's normal i was like
well he was like yeah you cleansed your
soul it's like so you shouldn't they
tick talkers
yeah okay so too we're going to be
playing
wait what the [ __ ] is it called because
honestly i'm kind of drunk we're gonna
be playing most likely too so we pointed
the person who's most likely to do such
thing
and that person has stuff we should
guess during this okay everyone get your
shots wrecked
who's most likely to make out with the
uber
have you seen the video before do you
remember no okay
who's i'm gonna do guy in the middle i'm
gonna do like this one
okay on the right
take a shot who's most likely to get
arrested
um um
i'm gonna go with the same thing
arrested probably larry
probably larry for sure take that shot
for what
sometimes you just gotta let it out okay
one to ten how drunk are we going
babe look at the bottle
[Music]
you look like a booger he's swaying
that's you know he's drunk
a pretty booger okay i'm drunk
who is that okay james i need you to
tell us
which one has the best look okay i got
liquor before he got cancelled
i don't know when this video maybe i
want to see
[Music]
uh this might have been right before
where's my highlight where's my okay
we're gonna go you can't look at me yet
mario and then me
which one has the best wait me again i
just put highlight on i honestly
i probably would say larry what what the
[ __ ]
where did i go wrong where did i go
wrong uh the blue contour
you look pretty ah you could be like the
villain in the powerpuff girls
mojo jojo i can't do this video anymore
i'm too drunk
get up yes sir
[Music]
help
this is what happens when you let
demogorgons out of their oh
okay everyone welcome back to the mario
show where we get to ask the questions
and they get to give us
answers today we're going to be having
two guest stars please
welcome buttercup
is that me oh hey buttercup
hi hi jacob
i actually don't even know what the [ __ ]
is her name did we just take a shot
what what is that oh he got us
oh eww most likely to hit someone with
the car
um i'm gonna go guy in the middle
eat that one okay the pink nails
me ravan oh we're gone move on
take the shower on what did you take a
shot run everyone would be easy
okay so we have two more questions for
most likely two one two three go
who's most likely to argue with the
police officer
okay i'm gonna pick the guy in the
orange just because it's bound to be him
at some point
yeah orange argue with the uh probably
mario
no sure mario
oh that's interesting because i think
you would argue more than so you would
already take a shot
wait what oh
[Music]
no wonder
yes last question who's most likely to
spill candy from a little kid
we're gone sit hands down just kidding
he wouldn't do that
i've stolen candy from a kid
we're going to all have one bottle of
water each and we'll be back
uniforms over here buttercup
i'm not gonna lie you guys ravon did
spill coffee on
my pants ravon what do you have to say
you're pretty you're so sweet
oh you guys are so pretty i love you
guys
hey boys
wait where's blossom blossom i'm ready
hey guys what's up ravana here fully
sober
y'all i'm feeling really green how's my
eye shadow look look
so okay that's it
did you just find bite my finger we are
now
going to create don't care
we're now going to create a tick tock
that's for mermaid
raven please get up please please for
the love of god
[Music]
let's make a tick tock this is the sound
we're doing
buttercup
[Music]
if you saw that tik tok i apologize you
guys thank you so much
for watching that's like the end of the
video yeah
oh wow he has he almost has 731
000 subscribers and i've never heard of
him
wow is there anymore
robot wake up it's the outro thank you
so much for watching we love you guys
thank you for watching the three
followers
what he's that one has how are you
literally famous i did not realize he
was that big
i have never heard of him oh how did um
[Music]
james charles get cancelled i never
heard about that oh he was like texting
minors
okay guys let me know what you thought
of this reaction
in the comments don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell and let me know in the
comments what we should react to next
time i will talk to you guys
later